gout
is an arthritic disease of your joints
caused by too much uric acid
in your body normally your liver
processes various substances in your
body
including purines which are components
of genetic material
found both inside your cells and in some
foods you eat
when your liver breaks down purines a
waste product called uric acid is
produced
your body disposes of this waste through
your kidneys
which remove it from your blood
when your liver produces too much uric
acid
or your kidneys do not remove enough of
it from your body
excess uric acid accumulates in your
blood
resulting in a condition called
hyperuricemia
caffeinated beverages affect the waste
removal function of your kidneys
by increasing your urine output which
eliminates too much water from your body
a condition called dehydration
dehydration can result in a higher
concentration of uric acid
in your body's fluids when the
concentration of uric acid becomes too
high from any of these sources
it can no longer stay dissolved
the excess uric acid begins to form
needle-like crystals inside your joints
most commonly in your big toe
formation of uric acid crystals leads to
an inflammatory response
white blood cells from your immune
system attack the uric acid crystals
resulting in joint pain and inflammation
this is called an acute gout attack
if left untreated elevated uric acid
levels
may result in lumpy deposits of uric
acid around your joint
called a toefuse causing additional
joint pain
and disfigurement
treatment for acute gout attacks
includes
colchicine to prevent or reduce joint
inflammation
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs to
reduce pain and inflammation
and steroid drugs such as prednisone
treatment for chronic gout includes
drugs that promote uric acid excretion
and drugs that inhibit uric acid
production by your body
lifestyle changes to prevent recurrent
or chronic gout
include reducing red meat and shellfish
in your diet
limiting the consumption of alcohol
which is high in purines
limiting caffeinated beverages
exercising regularly
and drinking plenty of water